European Union farm ministers meet
Monday to try to agree ways to reform
the e use common agricultural policy or
cap the system is aimed at guaranteeing
good living standards for farmers and
stable food supplies at fair prices for
consumers it also helps to foster rural
development and protect the environment
The ministers want to come up with a
common position on four main rules that
will govern the reforms the cap has been
notoriously difficult to change and
attempts to reform it routinely caused
an outcry spending on agriculture
accounts for a big slice of the annual
EU budget just less than forty percent
this year although it has been
decreasing in share the global economic
downturn is making the negotiations
tougher particularly as the 27 member
nations strive to finalize the e use
next long-term budget for the 2014 to
2020 period the Irish presidency will
lead discussion on a proposal for the
reform rules on behalf of the council
the presidency must take into account
the views of all Member States and the
European Commission to forge a solid
compromise it can then discuss the plans
with the European Parliament which
adopted its position on the reform on
March 13 we hope that we can confirm the
council's negotiating mandate that is a
mandate that reflects the divergent
views of 27 different member states
which will enable the Irish presidency
on behalf of the council then to reflect
a council position in the discussions
with the other institutions the
Parliament and the Commission when we
start that process in April the items
the ministers will pour over include
rules on direct payments to farmers a
common organisation of the markets in
agricultural products rural development
support and the way the cap is financed
managed and monitored if agreement is
found at this council the presidency
aims to clinch a comprehensive political
Accord on the reforms with the
Parliament by june 30